if you're a billionaire most people
would agree that you're too big to fail
even if your assets plummeted at 80
percent you'd be left with hundreds of
millions of dollars if you were
originally a multi-billionaire you may
still even have a billion dollars left
while this is true for cash billionaires
with a little debt not all billionaire's
fortunes are built upon such solid
foundations in many cases a recession or
downturn in the market is all that's
needed to wipe them out and no one knows
this better than sean quinn
in 2008 sean was the richest man in
ireland worth an estimated 6 billion
dollars but by 2011 sean had not only
lost at all but he was bankrupt and owed
an eye watering at 3.5 billion dollars
to this day sean hasn't been able to
climb out of this hole and his once
seemingly indestructible fortune is just
a blip in history
so here's why sean quinn went from being
ireland's richest man to fine for
bankruptcy in three years
taking a look back sean was born on
december 5th 1947 in a small village
called daryl in in northern ireland
sean's family was extremely poor farmers
who were just trying to survive on a
daily basis
so sean never had the luxury of focusing
on education or building a career he had
to spend all his time helping run the
farm and he would even drop out of
school when he was 14 unable to read or
write
after he dropped out sean searched for
alternative ways that he can make the
family farm profitable as their farm had
never been very lucrative when it came
to growing crops or livestock it took a
bit of time to come up with a solution
but sean eventually realized that his
farm was filled with one substance that
was in high demand and no we're not
talking about gold or drugs we're
actually talking about gravel sean
borrowed 100 pounds and started
extracting gravor from his 23 acre
family farm he would then wash the
gravel and sell it to local builders
selling gravel wasn't particularly
lucrative but jon had plenty of gravel
and it was a very cheap business to run
soon enough sean made his business
official by registering it as sean queen
tourist limited over time he expanded
into selling other construction
materials as well but by far his biggest
jump forward was when he started selling
cement which would become the basis of
his fortune as this meant business
started to pick up steam sean entered
some more difficult industries such as
glass and plastics sean opened up loads
of subsidiaries throughout the 1970s and
80s but all of them were concentrated on
construction you see sean was able to
build up a substantial number of
construction contracts through the
gaelic athletic association which is a
group focused on promoting irish
sporting and culture sean felt
comfortable dealing with members of this
group and for decades he avoided
venturing into anything else but
eventually in the 1990s sean would take
his first steps outside of construction
sean didn't just jump into starting a
tech company or investing into crypto
though in terms of diversification sean
looked for industries that had similar
stability and consistency to
construction which led him to finance in
1996 sean founded quinn financial
services which offered a variety of
different financial services but their
most popular business was insurance this
probably had to do with the fact that
sean was extremely popular within
northern ireland though his wealth had
skyrocketed from zero to hundreds of
millions over the past few decades to
most people who actually knew sean he
was just another hard-working irishman
sure he had nice houses and cars but he
never lost his connection to the
everyday man
in fact he was constantly building up
his relationship with this community
instead of bringing in highly educated
people from the us and europe shawn
preferred to employ as many local people
as he could
at its peak sean employed 8 000 people 5
500 of which were from ireland given
sean's strong connection with the
community many irish people far
preferred insuring themselves with quinn
financial services as opposed to some
large european bank eventually the
company would grow so large that they
would actually buy out ireland's second
biggest health insurance provider bupa
ireland in 2007 for 150 million euros
this was a pretty big bet but jon was
easily able to afford it after all his
finance company had turned over 123
million euros worth of profit within the
first six months of 2006. aside from the
financial industry sean also dove into
the hospitality industry throughout the
1990s sean purchased a plethora of
hotels across ireland the uk and eastern
europe one of his most famous
acquisitions came in 2004 when he
purchased a proc hilton for 145 million
euros sean didn't let all these new
investments distract him from growing
his core business either in the 2000s he
was actively expanding the construction
business into chemicals radiators and
energy
at this point sean's business was
definitely way too big and way too
diversified to fail but it only took one
bad investment to erase decades of work
the bulk of shawn's financial pain
circles back to a fateful investment
into the anglo-irish bank looking back
this bank was notorious for funding rich
property developers with money that they
would turn around and gamble on
speculative real estate place in
retrospect it's extremely obvious why
you wouldn't want to invest in such a
company during the housing bubble but at
the time it was much less obvious from
sean's perspective the bank had
relationships with a bunch of wealthy
real estate developers so it seemed like
a pretty safe bet
throughout the early 2000s shawn
invested a total of 1.3 billion into the
bank growing a 28 stake if this
investment were to collapse it would
have already been quite painful but sean
wouldn't be in risk of bankruptcy this
however would change when the stock of
the bank started to drop in late 2007.
you see sean thought that this was just
a great biotic opportunity
and that it was just a matter of time
until the bank recovered so sean doubled
down on his bet and it took out loans
against other companies to buy contract
for differences or cfds cfds are a type
of financial derivative and its inner
workings are quite complex but all you
need to know is that it's a form of
leveraged trading this means the gains
and losses in share price are amplified
for example if the share price recovers
2 you might make 20
but the problem is that if it drops 2
percent you lose 20
now there's no excuse for borrowing
money to make such a gamble but sean
wasn't an idiot either there were a
couple of big misleading green flags
that led him down this path first of all
anglo-stock was performing way better
than the rest of the banking industry
this doesn't mean that english stock was
at all-time highs but it was down less
than the overall financial industry this
made sean confident that other investors
also saw the potential in anglo but the
reality was that a dozen extremely well
the individuals were propping up the
share price
once anglo stock started to fall anglo
allegedly reached out to its top 10
biggest investors and directors and gave
them loans to buy anglo stock apparently
this is why shawn himself was buying
anglo stock so all this extra buying
pressure created a false sense of
security aside from popping up the stock
price anglo was allegedly propping up
their fundamentals anglo had loaned out
money to one of their rivals who then
turned around and deposited the money
back into anglo which made it seem like
anglo was more solvent than they really
were this charade helped anglo stay
afloat through the beginning of the
financial crisis but as other financial
institutions started to collapse angler
would collapse as well
and sean was basically all in on anglo
got obliterated
given that sean had lost it all on anglo
stock he was no longer able to pay back
his loans to anglo and anglo would come
after sean shawn and his family have
fired back with lawsuits against anglo
claiming that they basically propped up
the stock price and fundamentals it was
never really determined if these
allegations were true or not but here's
what we know
anglo did in fact give out a loan to top
investors directors and a rival who in
turn invested back into anglo but anglo
claims that there were no laws being
broken they were simply fulfilling their
roles as a bank by loaning out money and
giving out financial advice it's not
like they were committing securities
fraud or running a pump and dump also it
wasn't the bank's fault that sean went
all in on anglo stock he was clearly
smart enough in the 1990s to diversify
away from construction he should have
known not to put all his eggs in one
basket regardless of how confident he
was in the investment with not enough
money left to run his businesses sean
would voluntarily file for bankruptcy in
northern ireland but even this would end
poorly you see sean's choice to file
from bankruptcy in northern ireland was
strategic because the law in northern
ireland allows bankrupt businesses to
return to business after 12 months
however a judge would overturn this
bankruptcy filing asserting that sean's
main businesses were run out of ireland
and not just northern ireland this made
it impossible for sean to restart his
business without paying back his loans
but without his businesses there was no
chance that he could ever pay them back
so sean was stuck in a catch-22
situation this went on until ireland
decided to nationalize anglo-irish bank
and bail them out with 34 billion euros
once the bank was nationalized it wasn't
just a bank who wanted chant to repay
his loans now it was the state and they
were looking to take away all his
remaining assets seeing this sean and
his kids would try to weigh as many
assets as they could offshore but they
would quickly be caught and charged
resulting in sean being sent to joe for
nine weeks and with that sean had
officially fallen from being islands
which is men to being a convict
all these lawsuits and court battles
have been extremely expensive for both
sean and the state apparently the battle
cost the state a total of 170 million
euros as of 2019 so they finally decided
to settle the case the court has agreed
to let the queen family keep 440 million
euros if they liquidate their remaining
assets and pay back at least 500 million
euros to the state so it looks like the
quinn family will end up walking away
with a large sum of money nonetheless
this has left a lot of the public
divided a lot of people in ireland still
strongly support sean suggesting that
sean made a calculated risk on anglo and
if it wasn't for anglo's deception
sean's investment would have panned out
they feel that ireland unfairly took
sides with anglo and that shawn is
innocent on the other side of spectrum
critics argued that it doesn't matter
whether anglo was deceptive or not
sean's leveraged investment was
extremely irresponsible and he's simply
facing the consequences of his actions
not to mention it it was the people who
trusted sean and brought his insurance
policies that sustained the most
impactful losses in the meantime it
looks like sean is still walking away
with 440 million euros critics also
point to shawn's instinct to hide away's
assets as a glimpse at his true colors
at the end of the day shawn started off
as a poor farm boy who used his
ingenuity and humbleness to reach
unthinkable heights at one point he was
cherished by the irish and regarded as a
miraculous success story but it only
took one overconfident investment to
destroy the empire and reputation that
he had so painstakingly built who do you
think is to blame sean or anglo comment
that down below also drop a like if you
think that greed kills and of course
consider joining our discord community
to suggest future video ideas and
consider subscribing see more questions
logically answered but until then i'm
hari and i'll see you guys on the next
one
you